among the world's richest people two
indian businessmen have for years had
their place secured mukesh ambani and
galtom adani when the pandemic began
mukesh ambani was india's wealthiest
person he is the chairman managing
director and largest shareholder of
reliance industries but now billionaire
industrialist
andani has replaced him he is now the
world's fifth richest person according
to forbes this year alone galton madani
added 30 billion dollars to his wealth
outpacing other billionaires at the same
time scores of indians are being pushed
into poverty as the gap between the rich
and the poor
increases again
for more we go to delhi and dw's charu
kartikeya
tara good to see you um eight groups are
saying this trend
that we're seeing is reversing years of
progress when it comes to lifting people
out of poverty tell us more
hi chris good to see you and yes of
course the
this report the trends that is flagging
it has been flagged by several other
reports as well there are several rich
lists that point out that number of uh
billionaires in india is continuously
rising there's the haroon list there's
bloomberg
there's forbes several other lists are
corroborating the fact but yes of course
that wealth is not being distributed and
which is leading to this growing gap
between the rich and the poor in india
that is also corroborated by several
reports here for example the national
family health survey which the
government of india conducts every four
years uh there are independent think
tanks also that have been bringing this
fact out uh there are international
think tanks as well for example the
paris based world inequality lab has
also corroborated the figures saying
that uh
10 of india's population captures uh
more than half of its national wealth
now this has several uh uh repercussions
for uh the poor for those who uh
struggle in making their ends meet and
this has only the pandemic has only
exacerbated the situation
we are well aware that millions of
people lost their jobs millions uh
were pushed into extreme poverty in fact
government
the federal government itself has been
going to town claiming that it provided
free food to at least 800 million people
during the pandemic now that's a very
very significant number and that it just
goes on to suggest that things are
so hard for millions of indians while a
few on the other hand
keep getting richer and richer and the
pandemic has only
further exacerbated that chris
let's talk about one of these few that
you mentioned there gautama dhani has
become the fifth richest person in the
world by adding 30 billion dollars to
his wealth this year alone how
well it helps that
he's in the good books of the federal
government got the madani's
business uh it it it acquired new
heights when
the current prime minister narendra modi
was the chief minister of gujarat that's
when gautam adani got the initial philip
to his business empire which has only
expanded ever since and uh during the
term of the pandemic the adani adani
enterprises has ventured into several
domains largely in the infrastructure
space so from ports from seaports to
airports to coal mining and now even
cement the latest deal for which adani
was in the headlines was acquiring
india businesses of uh holsham india and
now becoming essentially a cement giant
also in india so all these acquisitions
have uh made adani uh look like an
industrialist who is ready to take risks
and further expand the basket for which
uh
the dhani group of industries is known
and
which is why now he is uh racing ahead
of of all those other billionaires uh
that uh the india story was a synonymous
with and now adani is uh replacing those
names
dw's charocartica in delhi ciara thank
you